I always wonder when someone like you
comes on the program who has this crazy
unique skill how did you figure out that
you could do this when did you know that
your lips could do this well I've been
doing arts since I could hold a crayon
right and painting sewing metal smithing
every medium I can get my hands on and
back in 2001 I was getting ready to go
see some band I don't even remember it
was put on my red lipstick blotted it
and saw the lip print and said you know
son of a [ __ ] I can paint with that
like so you're completely self-taught in
this technique yeah I went to school for
metal smithing and ceramics I mean like
I said like any medium I could get my
hands on I used to actually say when
people would even call myself an artist
for a long time people would ask me you
know
what do you do I make [ __ ] I just I do
and always looking for new technique
sure any way to express yourself and
then you find this and this has sort of
really taken off for you let's look at
we have some works of art behind the
couch here and we can push in on these
they're absolutely incredible there's
David Bowie right there and this is all
done with your lips correct yes
absolutely fantastic I think below David
Bowie is is that Hunter s Thompson yes
firing a gun right there absolutely
incredible and you don't use brushes or
anything I have started doing more
mixed-media stuff like painting on the
backgrounds portraits that you know I
don't even sketch with a pencil it's
just my lips right just a different way
of painting okay and this is Audrey
Hepburn behind you and again all all you
using your lips and I'm just curious
what is the technique is there a special
technique involved do you ever is it
just lips do you ever involve the tongue
when you're making stuff and I mean come
on grow up these are artistic questions
my class yeah tongue in painting no but
I don't know I have no idea that's what
was so fun about it is is the
problem-solving and trying to figure out
how I could make different shapes and
you know those those really crappy
websites that are dedicated to making
fun of those the girls on like social
media making the duck faces yeah but
that's unfortunately that's it's not a
very flattering process when I paint and
I have to make that face and you make
the face for me right now what's the
yeah you go do that you gotta kind of
distort your face I did I did acting
when I was younger and when I was a
little kid I would just make faces in
the mirror and now it's doing right now
you might have a future in this you
should try it you know who'd be good at
this painting as Donald Trump would be
good you know you know and then he could
go paint at home and maybe channel some
of that rage yeah that's good luck with
that now I want to mention a lot of the
proceeds for this go to a really good
cause
I try to do as much charity stuff as I
can I do signed limited-edition numbered
screen prints of my work and I usually
donate to like the Juvenile Diabetes
Research Foundation or the American
Diabetes Association I'm on an aniline
animus insulin pump I'm a cyborg
I enjoy technique is the word you use
for you have that pump with you all the
time right my pancreas pretty much
doesn't produce enough insulin right so
I have to give it to myself manually so
I just I wear a pump I've been wearing
it for 11 years now Wow and then you you
raise a lot of money for this cause
that's fantastic
every little bit helps I hope I can help
out so